le parcours est très bien linde
entrailles donc c'est
ce samedi 16 octobre plus de 600
courageux ont pris le départ du premier
élan courte championne ce trail un tracé
composé à 95% de chemins naturel belle
course belle montée qui cassent bien
épaté comptant est arrivé et il a bien
fait du bien l'arrivée et la faim dans
transmis naturel magnifique magnifique
conte signature franchement c'était
c'était top outre l'arrivée dans le parc
france miniature l'autre point fort du
parcours était sa dimension olympique
c'était l'originalité du parcours qui
était organisée aujourd'hui c'était un
de gravir la colline qui demain en 2024
accueillera effectivement l'épreuve vtt
et c'était aussi l'occasion de passer
par france miniature qui est un site
touristique et puissant il parce qu'on
voit toute la france soit les
participants donc c'était l'originalité
du parcours les trois passages à travers
la célèbre colline n'étaient pas les
seules difficultés du parcours même pour
les vainqueurs du jour c'était pas
facile je pensais qu'après la colline ça
irait mieux est en fait la montée pour
rentrer jusqu'ici a été finalement
difficile aussi la colline d'elancourt
c'est un coin au jeu en train de souvent
l'habitude vient faire plusieurs
dizaines de monter donc là trois montées
s'est passé assez vite mais c'était
vraiment sympa comme comme parcours fort
de ce succès auprès des coureurs l'élan
courses shopping ce trade devrait être
reconduit reste à savoir si cela sera
avant ou après le jeux olympiques des
travaux devant commencer avant l'année
prochaine sur la colline